hi welcome to Mountain View California
I'm speaking here at Google's
headquarters and I'd like to tell you
about something I'm really excited about
it's called Android and it's a new
open-source operating system and
software platform for mobile phones just
like I learned how to write great
services and software upon free tools
for the web like Linux and GNU now with
Android you'll be able to do the exact
same things on mobile phones the
software is all free the source is
completely available and we expect great
new powerful applications to be
developed on it the SDK is being
released right now and you can download
it and to show you some of the
highlights and some of the applications
we've already developed here Steve you
probably been hearing a little bit about
the G phone lately I'm here to tell you
there is actually no G phone instead I'd
like to introduce you to the Android
platform this is a platform we hope will
enable people to create thousands of G
phones
the first device I'd like to show you
today is a prototype that I've been
living with for about the past six
months because in order to create a
great product you actually have to live
with it this particular device is
running a full version of the Android
software stack that has all the
functionality you would expect in a
basic phone here's an example of a home
screen this is a place where you have
access to all of your favorite
applications such as your browser maps
or contacts if you want to call somebody
just type their name and hit dial and
I'm calling my friend Eric of course one
of the things that we've built into the
topher development kit is the ability to
interact and integrate applications with
one another so another example using
contacts let's say I want to find out
where Erin lives I simply go and type
her name and when I bring up for contact
and select her address
it'll take me right to the Maps
application and it's going to zoom right
in to show me where Erin lives if I
select to see on the map that we notice
that she lives on amphitheatre Parkway
but maybe I'm not quite sure where that
is so I want to zoom out a little bit to
see what freeway that might be close to
there we can see that it's near the
highway 101 now if I go back to the home
page
one of the other things I want to show
you is the ability for devices on using
the Android platform to receive
notifications for example here I just
receive the notification from my friend
Lexi that says that Pizza sounds good
that must be what she wants for dinner
you notice that it first showed up at
the top of the screen and it told me
that the contents of that message if I
want to go and read that message all I
have to do is navigate up and you can
see up there's my notification from Lexi
says Pizza sounds good if I want to
reply I just hit the enter key and I can
go into my text messaging application
say great and away we go it sounds like
we're having pizza for dinner tonight
the next device I'd like to show you is
a more high-end prototype that includes
advanced features such as high speed 3G
networking accelerated 3d graphics and
touchscreen let me show you the browser
application our web browser is based on
the open source web kit the industry
standard these days it's the one that
allows you to see web pages just as they
would appear on your desktop another
thing that you'll notice about our web
browser is that it's loading over the
Fast 3G data network this device is
capable of accessing the Internet at 3G
speeds and loading web pages quite fast
now the page is loaded here and we're
zoomed in a little bit so if I want to
see more of the page I can simply grab
it and pan around a little bit and if I
want to see the page in its full glory I
can simply zoom out and see it just as
it would appear on my desktop we also
have a rich visual history for our
browser go in here and I can look at the
history for my browser and I can see all
the sites that I visited recently the
next application I'd like to show you is
global time this shows you the rich
graphical powers of the Android platform
and in this case it's using the 3d
OpenGL ES to render a globe here and
allow me to very easily spin it with my
finger I can also play with the earth
while spinning around the Android
graphics API is allow you to very easily
mix 3d and 2d graphics next I'd like to
show you some of the advanced 3d
hardware capabilities of this prototype
using quake
any application that is written to the
Android OpenGL s AP is will be able to
take full advantage of any hardware
acceleration now I'd like to show you
the Maps application I happen to be here
at the city of San Francisco using the
touchscreen capabilities of this device
I can pan around the city of San
Francisco and watch those map tiles load
for me at 3G speeds one of the benefits
of the Android platform
is that we build in basic functionality
like map views so your application
doesn't have to reinvent all the
functionality in maps if you want to
build something on top of it
Here I am at the Embarcadero and Street
View starting from wherever I was on
maps if I want to I can simply take my
finger and I can move that image around
and I can pan around and see what the
Embarcadero looks like well I could also
zoom in that was just a preview of some
of the things the Android platform can
do we can't wait to see what developers
will come up with next welcome back I
hope you enjoyed seeing some of the
applications we've built already but the
best applications are not here yet
that's because they're going to be
written by you and many other developers
just like you we'd like to reward these
developers and to recognize them as much
as possible
so we've set aside 10 million dollars
which we're going to give away to the
people who develop the best applications
using Android we're looking forward to
seeing some really great apps once which
are innovative make use of the great
functionality available in Android and
on mobile phones and things that are
really original that haven't been seen
before I look forward to seeing all of
your work
you